so
okay so flat taxes who would be against
flat taxes
rich people i thought poor people would
be against flat taxes that's crazy right
that you would think that i would if
you're
if you're taxing everyone at fifteen
percent
twenty percent i mean in theory the rich
are getting forty percent the poor are
paying you know nothing
you just don't tax them if they make a
certain amount or less if
they're below the poverty line you just
don't tax them period by the way i think
that's a great idea
i i think that's a great idea if you
make below
a certain better than a welfare system
by the way here's the thing watch this
watch this this just took us to a
completely different place which would
you rather have you guys ready
which would you rather honestly i'm
asking this to everybody listen to this
what she just said when we're in the
different free we just made a right
u-turn we're going this way watch this
yeah would you
rather have a minimum wage
or if you make less than 40 grand a year
you don't pay any taxes
hello which would you take no tax
forget the minimum wage are you
seriously a minimum wager i'm not a
minimum wage
what shirt was he wearing last week
all right here's a little lesson
danielle before you rip me a new one
he's making that up before you go in on
me i suppose i'm gonna do
this all right one of my best friends in
in south florida he's a guy um
that he's he is the champion of the
president you have a friend in south
florida
okay yes everywhere you go you run into
somebody that knows this guy adamites
you call them atomizers
yeah they're out there subway mafia so
but but continue yeah yeah
give me a new one my my mama was born
and raised in pearsall texas
the the average home price in pearson
texas is around
73 000 my father was born and raised in
east haven connecticut it's east of new
haven
average home price there's about 250
thousand dollars
should the average worker make 15 in
pearsall
and in east haven clearly not okay good
see next this is why i'm against a
federal minimum wage but in certain
connecticut rich areas or you know south
florida boca raton there needs to be
you've never met east haven it's not
it's not it's not where it's at can you
get used to being in boca raton more
often i just want to know that i'm so
loving it here guys okay
because i heard from the people at louie
bosses you had a great time last night
oh my gosh
they called me this morning they said oh
by the way
so you are in favor of of governors or
mayors
implementing some sort of minimum wage
but not federal government
did i understand that correctly it is
the job of this this is why we have the
separation
all i was saying is i mean let's take
the camera off i'm trying to see if paul
was paying attention so if i signal to
you that's what i mean but don't worry
about it you missed the signal everybody
else got what i was saying there's an
egg white signal okay no no the egg
white signal to paul is get off your
instagram
well you guys stop dm and your girl okay
and you know i'm watching but you guys
are pregnant
but we know that's not a truth oh sixth
place
stop that buddy my god so paul and
you and brady
danielle i know this was just accidental
how we got into the conversation
i'm actually just this if you actually
pitched you make less than 30 grand or
40 grand don't pay any taxes
but let's eliminate minimum wage so so
so meaning if you're making
720 an hour 725 to an hour whatever the
number is right now 15 grand well you're
making more you're
you know no you pick the number you're
you're making 10 bucks and i write a job
20 grand a year
20 grand a year if you're making 10
bucks an hour 20 if you want to pay
taxes how much are they taking taxes out
of you if you're making 10 bucks an hour
well i don't think you pay any taxes if
you make less than i think
12 grand or 10 grand like zero zero tax
i'm saying
40. okay take minimum wage out
no taxes paid until you make 40 grand
sure
so the only number we deal with is what
raising or lowering that number not
minimum wage
so which means i like that if we go four
years from now five years from now 10
years from now due to inflation that 40
goes 45.
that 45 goes 50. you don't pay any taxes
below that if you make about 50 you pay
taxes
i mean i'm in eliminate eliminate
eliminate the minimum wage minimum wage
you're going to
and eliminate minimum wage and eliminate
the
the progressive tax just put a flat tax
on you're going to make government
growth
why is government going to work what do
you mean it's going to work you do
something that simple government
actually works
it functions that is an incredible why
don't why don't why aren't these kind of
conversations you give me frosting on
the cake of term limits and we're all
good i mean look at
look at pat toomey pat toomey's my hero
oh my gosh i've got like the pat to me
poster on my ceiling
toomey's your hero tournaments and
sticking to them
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye